GUEST SPEAKER: You ready?
The project that I chose to
work on is a 2D puzzle game,
and it's based on a
puzzle version of Tetris
that I've created
over many years.
I programmed in
different formats.
But I haven't figured out
a good way to deploy it,
so I thought maybe Unity would
be a good option because it
claims to be cross platform.
So, anyway, so I'm a one-person
project, and that's OK.
It was a fascinating
learning experience,
and I made decent progress.
The game that you're
going to see is not very--
oh, something's wrong with it.
The Canvas needs to get
away from the playing board.
Is there a way?
Anyway, so the game is
very low-end graphics.
It's very bare bones,
but conceptually, it's
an implementation of Tetris,
with the variation that only
certain pieces are used.
And it has a puzzle objective,
so you could actually
win the game or solve it.
The objective is-- the simple
objective is a wipeout--
where you want to clear
the board exactly,
so that the last piece
clears all the row.
Is everyone familiar with Tetris
and the row-clearing mechanism
[INAUDIBLE], I hope?
So you'll see it and figure
it out if you're not.
If I can--
I knew I wanted to do a
2D game, grid-type puzzle
because that's what I've
been working on a lot
is developing various
ideas for logic puzzles
that use 2D grids.
And I thought Tetris
might be too ambitious,
so I was looking
at the tutorials I
found on Unity sites.
There were some-- there
was one for Minesweeper,
so I was originally
going to do that.
But then when I found
the Tetris tutorial,
I said, oh, maybe
I can go with this.
My first step was to implement
the Tetris tutorial--
implement the code from
the Tetris tutorial,
which that code was
for a full Tetris
game with a 10-wide board
and all the pieces that
are standard Tetris.
But what I wanted
is just a couple
of pieces that work
well for the wipe
out games that I
do-- the puzzles.
So I just needed a
T-piece and an L-piece,
so that's all I implemented.
So I adapted the
Tetris code a lot.
So let me just jump a bit
and show you a quick demo
if I could move my mouse.
Oh, it's two screens.
So before-- oh, yeah, the
game is already going.
So you can select
which width you want.
The board can be--
I'll show you how that moves--
the board can be
seven-wide, or we'll
start with five-wide
because that's easier
to finish the wipeout.
10-wide is really slow.
It's possible to play this
wipeout game with wider boards,
but it just takes so much
longer, and it's tedious.
So I find that five, six,
and seven are the most
fun and challenging
levels, and the game
can be very challenging.
You need to learn
patterns, as you'll see.
So then you have the choice
of three piece options,
as either a T-piece,
which I'll start with,
or you can do an L-piece, or
the T and L together, which
under the current limitation,
they're randomly chosen,
which makes the
game extremely hard
because it's much
easier to solve
if you can plan ahead a little.
Because you get to
the point where--
well, I'm jumping ahead.
So let's do the T-piece and
show the game in action.
So this is what it looks like.
We start with a piece
down at the bottom.
It manually drops-- are my
cursor keys going to work here?
Yeah, so there's
basically four--
the four arrow keys are
used to control this.
The pieces fall like in
Tetris, so you can rotate.
There is only one
rotate, so right up arrow
is rotate clockwise.
And you could drop a piece,
and then the rows clear.
That's the Tetris mechanism.
So now this takes a little
longer to do a wipeout,
but I'll show you
the basic idea.
The trick is that
you learn patterns,
so you'll start to
see a pattern here.
So I can clear
that, and now I can
clear a row by putting this.
It takes four pieces
to clear a row.
So eight more pieces
and I'll be down--
all but the white dots.
So let's just plow through that,
so you can see what happens.
[LAUGHTER]
One more.
So it's-- you see the pattern,
so part of what I think is fun
about this game is
learning these patterns.
It's challenging to figure
out how to learn pattern.
There sort of like macros.
Oh.
[APPLAUSE]
Look at that.
Thank you.
So let's just try one--
I don't know how much time I
have, so I'll just do one more,
so we can discuss
what went into it.
There were a number of steps
forward in the learning
experience.
First, was implementing
the Tetris game, modified
to use only the two pieces,
so I started with just the two
pieces.
And then, the next
step, I wanted to set up
controls to let me select.
So the first thing I did
was the width buttons--
to modify the width.
There's just one
thing that's control,
which is the right border,
as you saw it moves around.
So learning to move that was
my first learning experience.
I was happy when I
got that to work.
And I had to figure
out along the way
how to make buttons work--
how to connect to them
and run the scripts for
buttons and things like that.
It was very challenging, and
I had never programmed in C#
before, so that was a
challenge in itself.
But I made progress with that.
Once I figured out buttons, I
said, I'm running with buttons.
I'm going to use buttons
for all they're worth.
So I try to do the Piece
Selection buttons and then
the Start buttons.
And the Stop button
doesn't quite work.
It sort of works, but it
seems to create something
wrong in the data structure, so
that when I run the next game,
it crashes.
So that's not good, so I
avoid the Stop button now.
So let me show you the six-wide
board with the T-piece also.
Maybe I should do
the L-piece just
to show you a different
piece because I may not
be able to get beyond this.
So how do I want to do this?
So, yeah, this will work.
So one of the
patterns you learn is
that with two L-pieces
together, you can
make a two-by-four rectangle.
So if I put this one
down here, then the other
completes the
two-by-four rectangle.
And that rectangle, you can see,
fills in the remaining pieces,
so that that wipes that one out.
[APPLAUSE]
And I won't have
time to finish it,
but I'll just show
you what happens
when have the end of pieces.
Let's do it with, say,
the five-wide board.
So you see-- so we randomly
get an L- or a T-piece now.
And notice there's
only one kind of L,
which is the L L,
not the reflected L.
So how do I want to do this?
So part of the problem here
is that this L will not
turn around to go in
the other direction.
Now if I'm fast, I can slip
things in before it falls.
[LAUGHTER]
So I implemented the
drop, so that it drops--
let me just get my piece ready--
I want it to go there.
So it will drop, but
not freeze the piece.
So the code actually waits
until there's a fall.
You see that every
second the piece
tries to fall another
step, and the piece
freezes when it can't
successfully fall
in response to a fall action.
So this isn't great.
PROFESSOR: Anybody
have any questions?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, you
can start asking questions
while I muck with this.
Nope.
AUDIENCE: Have you
actually completed it
with the RAM [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh,
yeah, absolutely.
It's just a little more
tedious, like I said.
It takes-- no, it's
definitely doable.
It just-- sometimes it takes
multiple tries because--
here's a trick.
Because I'm preparing for Ls.
So I didn't get an L, but
I could put a T in here.
If I get an L next, good,
then I could put this here.
Now if I an L, I'll wipe
out all those three rows.
So I want to do
things like that.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's see.
There-- and this could work.
I get another L. Nope--
didn't.
So how do I want to do this?
So you don't always
get the piece
you want, of course,
because it's random.
Let's see how this works.
This will get it down
to almost one row.
[ARGH]
Boo.
I didn't want more
L-pieces, but I have
to decide what to do with it.
I guess I'll just bite
the bullet and do that.
So now I'll try again.
Yes, now if I--
whichever-- I'd
prefer a T-piece now.
So I can get it
down to one cell.
I'm close to a wipeout,
but not what I wanted.
If I can get a T-piece,
so this is good.
I like getting-- making
the shape of a T-piece
at the bottom because
there is a way
to win if I get
the right pieces.
So, L-- I need a T and an
L. let's hope for an L next.
AUDIENCE: Yay.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yay.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think this is a fun game.
What was this-- there
was a second thing.
The scripting was
a big challenge,
and learning to get the
buttons to work properly.
Oh, the text-- that's
what I did last night.
I figured out how
to enable text.
Someone gave me a
hint that I wanted
to set enable true or something.
But it was very
hard in one script
that detected the wipeout.
So I wrote the code last
night to detect the wipeout
by checking for all
the rows cleared.
There's a grid that's hidden
behind this little matrix that
holds blocks.
And the script operates on
that, and so I had the script
that checks for the wipeout.
And if it finds
there's a wipeout,
then it needs to
call another script.
Well, it basically needs to
go tell the text to enable,
so that you can see it.
So I created the text and
disabled it at the start,
but then I needed to be
able to programmatically,
or in the script,
turn it off and on,
which these things sound
simple, but they are not trivial
when you're first
encountering them.
So I struggled-- doing
googling-- looking for things
like how to find an object.
And so there's find
object by type,
and then there is the
game object defined,
which let's you find by
name, which was very useful.
So once I figured that
out I could look up my--
I think it was a text object.
I had a text object
that I created,
but that wasn't good enough.
I needed to get the
text component itself.
So I had to call get
component and figure out
what kind of specifications
to put after that to tell it
what kind of component to find.
The syntax was tricky.
One website said you needed a
dot before the angle bracket
text and another one.
But what worked was not
having the dot there,
so there's misinformation out
there, or else Unity changed.
I don't know, but,
finally, I got it.
And I thought there
was a method called
enable that I could say enable
or disable, but turns out,
it's a variable.
It's a, I guess, a
component variable,
or something, that you
can set to true or false.
Finally, I figured
it out, and I was
able to get the
congratulatory text to appear
[APPLAUSE]